LOUIS GRAY: Welcome to Google
Developers Weekly for
September 9, 2013.
I'm Louis Gray, and this is our
highlight reel of what's
happening in the world
of Google Developers
on the set and off.
This week in our GDL studios
was another big one
internationally and also another
big one for our root
access series.
Martin Omander and Don Dodge
returned to our set for two
separate episodes.
The first, to encourage startups
to stop finding
excuses and break down barriers
to make their ideas
successful.
And later, touching on the hot
trend of indoor location
services, which is great news
for parents just like me who
have to know exactly where to
find bathrooms when we take
our kids to the mall.
Startups also find their start
in places well beyond Silicon
Valley, of course.
From Berlin, Martin Gorner
invited Nacho Coloma, author
of Simple DS and CTO of Koliseo
to help you make an
informed decision between
SQL and no SQL.
Koliseo, a ticketing platform
built on App Engine, scales is
offering to meet peak demands
and Nacho wants
you to do the same.
From Milan, Italy, Google
Developers expert Sandro
Paganotti demonstrated two key
features of HTML5, the
template and Shadow DOM.
As we often say here at the
Googleplex, when talking about
the Shadow DOM, there really is
no better way to teach your
browser to include a subtree
of DOM elements.
Moving from DOMs to documents,
and from Milan to the Big
Apple in New York City, Ibrahim
Ulukaya told those of
us who work on the YouTube API
the best way to get help and
find documents to make
our code even better.
As you can imagine, beyond the
documents, what I need, tips
for my apps to get smart, I
turn to GDL and YouTube.
From Buenos Aires, Nick
Bortolotti hosted developers
on the Google Maps team who
presented how you can connect
people to places using
the Places API.
Nick speaks quickly, but he
means every single word.
And finally, from our Tokyo
studio, Eiji Kitamura
discussed the Web Audio API,
which enables Chrome to
process and synthesize sound.
Outside of our GDL studios, the
big news in both Android
and candy world's this week was
the announcement of Kit
Kat as the name of our next
version of Android.
In news with more substance
and less chocolate,
[BELL RINGING]
we announced that Android
has passed one
billion activations worldwide.
Speaking of big numbers, coders
love a good challenge
and we have a great
one for you.
The Google Cloud Platform
Developer Challenge is looking
for people to build locally
relevant web applications that
solve real world problems.
And what's a challenge
without some prizes?
This one has cache awards.
So check it out!
Speaking of the Cloud, this
week we launched Pearson
correlation, a new feature in
Big Query enabling you to
compare data and look for
insights that you might not be
able to see otherwise.
Correlation also allows you to
test assumptions that you
might think be right
but you want to see
data to back you up.
Your intuition plus Big
Query correlation
makes a powerful team.
Now that you're exploring Big
Query, be sure to tune in
later today and watch Michael
Manoochehri and Felipe Hoffa
discuss Big Query correlation
and how you can use it to help
predict your future.
Our data predicts another great
week here on Google
Developers Live.
To make sure that you never miss
a thing from the world of
Google Developers, subscribe
to Google Developers on
YouTube and check out
the GDL schedule at
developers.google.com/live.
I'm Louis Gray and I'll
see you in the studio.